[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome
back to Google Cloud Next
2017 in San Francisco.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
a developer advocate
and host of "The Dev Show."
DREA ALPHONSO: And I'm Drea
Alphonso, a program manager
on Google for Education and one
of the house for "The G Suite
Show."
So this is the last day
of Google Cloud Next,
and what a week it's been.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's right, Drea.
Today is dedicated to open
source and cloud-native
architectures, with deep dives
on Kubernetes and TensorFlow.
We'll hear from startups and
the venture capital community
about how they're
leveraging the cloud--
just as action
packed as yesterday.
DREA ALPHONSO: And
speaking of yesterday, we
put together some of
our favorite moments
for you to enjoy.
And here they are.
URS HOLZLE: Good
morning and welcome
to the second day of Next.
Our network is probably the
largest global network today,
between 25% and 40% of
global internet user traffic.
We put a security chip
on all our new machines
to serve as the basis of trust
for that machine's identity.
In fact, it's so small
that I'm actually
wearing one on my earring here.
PRABHAKAR RAGHAVAN:
At G Suite, we're
obsessed with the idea of that
computers should constantly
raise the bar on what can
get done of the mundane so
that our users, your employees,
have more and more time
to focus on truly creative work.
CHET KAPOOR: The cloud enables
innovative business models,
new ways of you creating
and changing your business
that you wouldn't have
been able to do before.
JONATHAN ROCHELLE: Jamboard
is a whiteboard in the cloud,
in the meeting room, and
beyond your meeting rooms.
You just pick up
the stylus, and you
start thinking, communicating,
and working with your team.
BRIAN STEVENS: Why
do they come to GCP?
They want the world's
best security.
They want to be on a flywheel
of continued innovation,
all available through an API.
The core promise to developers
still remains the same--
bring your code, and Google
will handle everything else.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
that was day two.
Drea, you also had a
chance to talk with someone
about Stackdriver, right?
DREA ALPHONSO: You
know, I sure did.
I talked with Amir,
a product manager
on Stackdriver, about
monitoring, logging,
and diagnostics for the cloud.
Let's check it out.
Hi, everyone.
I'm here with Amir who's
leading a session about alerting
best practices called "The
Thin Line Between Informing
and Over-Informing" that
everyone will have access to
in the next couple of days.
So Amir, before we
dive into your session,
tell us more about
what you do at Google.
AMIR HERMELIN: OK.
Hi, Drea.
I'm also excited to be here.
So I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud Platform.
And I focus on our
Stackdriver services suite.
Stackdriver is all over is
all about monitoring, logging,
and diagnostics
for our users that
are running their applications
on cloud services.
And I'm based here
in Mountain View.
DREA ALPHONSO: Oh, nice.
Me, too.
So when it comes
to, as we mentioned
the topic of the session,
alerting best practices
but also learning more
about Stackdriver,
why is this important when
we're thinking about the cloud?
AMIR HERMELIN: So
over the years,
we work with a lot of
our users, making sure
that they have everything
set up correctly
and they're correctly
monitoring their applications.
And we realized that alerting is
the hardest part to get right.
And so we wanted to use this
opportunity to share the things
we've learned both with
Stackdriver and monitoring
inside Google to help our
users and users of other cloud
platform providers
get alerting right,
For example, we
come across cases
where users alert too
often, or they don't
alert on the right things.
And so we want to
share our insights.
DREA ALPHONSO: Right.
And then how does Stackdriver
fit into all of that?
AMIR HERMELIN: So
Stackdriver is our service
that enables users to
alert on things that they
run in the cloud.
But the session is also
applicable to users of other
either competing services or
free services, open source.
So it's really
applicable to anyone
that's running production
services in the cloud
and they want to make sure
that their users are presented
with their best foot forward.
DREA ALPHONSO: Right.
And so in addition to leading
some of the sessions on that,
I guess for you, what are
you most excited about when
it comes to the
future of the cloud
and when it comes to
the specific products
that you're working on?
AMIR HERMELIN: So
with a Stackdriver,
and generally in
cloud, I'm really
excited to see that
the focus is shifting
from maintenance and
that kind of overhead
to really innovation.
So users today
have better tools.
It's easier to set up and
require very low overhead.
And so they can focus their
efforts instead of maintaining,
on innovating.
And so that leads to better
applications and better
services and more exciting
things that we see out there.
DREA ALPHONSO: Right.
Exactly.
Well, Amir, thanks for joining
us today and giving us a little
sneak peek into your
sessions that you're
going to be doing Cloud Next.
And we'll definitely
have a chance
to check it out on YouTube
in our recorded sessions.
AMIR HERMELIN: Thank you, Drea.
DREA ALPHONSO: Thank you.
And of course, Timothy and I
got to spend some more time
in the Cloud Showcase.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
just like yesterday, we
thought, wouldn't it be cool if
we brought you along as well.
DREA ALPHONSO:
Let's check it out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So here
we are at the Jamboard.
And I'm standing with Ishwarya.
Ishwarya, you could you
tell the live stream viewers
what you do at Google?
ISHWARYA VENKATACHALAM:
Yeah, I'm
a product manager on
the Jamboard team.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So
for those few people
out there that don't yet know
what a Jamboard is, what is it?
ISHWARYA VENKATACHALAM:
Jamboard is
a fun, digital,
collaborative whiteboard.
Everyone loves how it looks.
It looks great in the room.
It's the first thing
people walk to.
And it's fun just to,
like, write on it.
The other thing it is, is it's
a great collaboration device
for people who are working,
for example, in remote offices.
So you could be in New York
and I could be in London,
and let's say you're
on a Jamboard.
I could pull up my
tablet, and we could
be jamming on the same file.
And we can collaborate
together, sketch.
Just anything that you would
do on like a normal whiteboard,
you could do on this Jamboard.
But instead of taking a picture
at the end of the session
and emailing it to me, we
could be doing it real time,
and you can just send
it to me, add people,
and then you can add
me as a collaborator.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
I know we spend a
lot of time on VC.
And there's
whiteboards behind us.
And you kind of sketch, and
sort of have to turn the camera
so you can see each other's--
DREA ALPHONSO:
JORDAN: take a picture
and send it over to people.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And it
just adds so much overhead
to the collaborative
process when
you're in different offices.
DREA ALPHONSO: Exactly.
Now, you mentioned, too,
like some of the sketching
and handwriting we can do.
But what are some of the other
kind of cool things that we
can I pop in and do
some brainstorming on?
ISHWARYA VENKATACHALAM:
Yeah, so, for example,
let's say we want to talk
about dogs during a meeting.
So once these images show up,
you can just pull them out
and then chain them up.
And then if you want to
delete, just slide them down.
So that something really cool.
And then another thing that
I love is the web search.
So anything that you would
search on, like, google.com,
you can just search in here.
Let's say I want to
go to New York City,
and I just want to pull
up a map of Manhattan.
This will take a
while, but you can just
like crop out the image
and pull it into your jam
and start writing on
it, mark places on it,
star places, send the
file to your friends.
You can all mark different
places at the same time,
pull in images,
like a donut place,
and then pull in images
of donuts from that place.
Another thing that's
pretty awesome
is the handwriting recognition.
So not everyone has amazing
handwriting like me.
So for people like those--
there we go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
was really cool.
ISHWARYA VENKATACHALAM:
And then you can also
scale these if you need to.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, thank
you for the quick tour
of the Jamboard.
DREA ALPHONSO: I'm
excited to start jamming.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is
the Meet the Experts area,
where developers
get to ask experts
from Google their questions
and work on solutions together.
I'm going to join Drea
over here, who's found
some of the Firebase crew.
And we're going to talk about
something that just launched.
Hey, y'all, how you doing?
DREA ALPHONSO: Hello there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All
right, so this is Doug.
And he's going to tell us about
something that just launched.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah,
so today we just
announced Google Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
which is a tool that lets
developers write back
end code that responds to events
in their Firebase project.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, I'm
really excited about this.
But some people might not
know exactly what that's for.
So why don't you tell us
what developer problems
does this solve?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah,
so what we found
is that developers
really don't want
to create their own servers,
maintain them, upgrade them,
and constantly deploy to them.
So what they'd rather do
is just write their code,
deploy it to Google
service, and let
Google handle all of
administrivia, the ops and all
that.
So it's really great
tool that developers
are using to build the back
ends for their mobile app.
DREA ALPHONSO: So tell us,
where do we go to learn more
and how do developers
get started with that?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah, so you
can go to firebase.google.com.
You can find the
Functions feature there.
And there's instructions
to get started.
So you can get going
with that right away.
DREA ALPHONSO:
Awesome. cool stuff.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thanks a lot, y'all.
We'll catch you soon.
All right, so here we
are in the G Suite area.
And I found Wes to
tell us a little bit
about what's going on.
Hi, Wes.
WES CHUN: Hey, everybody.
How are you doing?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
We're doing great.
Now, one of the
things that I think
is really cool about
what G Suite offers is
there's a little something
for people to build things
to solve problems
in their enterprise,
no matter what their
technical skill level.
Can you tell us a little
bit about that suite?
WES CHUN: Right, exactly.
So we have developer
tools for people
who are full-time developers.
But we also have
stuff where if you're
trying to get
something done, trying
to build like a little app to
like put together a report,
you don't have to be a
hardcore software engineer.
So we have a cool
new product called
App Maker which is a low-code
development environment where
you can go from idea to
app in days, not months.
And you don't really need
an engineering resource.
All you need to do is be
able to drag and drop things.
And you can build a simple
UI, add the connectors.
And boom, all of a sudden,
you are done and gone.
The next step up,
if you really want
to do a little bit more
work, is that App Maker
runs on top of App
Script, which is
Google's JavaScript in the
cloud environment that gives you
access and your apps access to
data and Google Apps, G Suite.
You can access other
Google services.
But you can also
make external calls
to like an outside
relational database.
And then for the
hardcore soft developers,
then we have the REST APIs
where you can actually
integrate Google Drive, Gmail,
calendar, sheets, and slides
into your applications.
DREA ALPHONSO: Oh,
a lot of stiff.
So there's also been a lot of G
Suite announcements and product
updates.
Talk to us about some
of your favorites
or highlights from those.
WES CHUN: OK, great.
This morning, we announced
that Team Drives is generally
available, which is really
exciting because now you
know if employees
move or change jobs,
you don't have to
worry about, oh,
who do we reassign the
ownership to, right?
It's crazy.
So everything is owned
by the organization.
And Team Drives is accessible
from the Drive API as well.
So your apps can integrate
with Team Drives.
The other announcement that
was exciting this morning
was Gmail add-ons, where you
can integrate your mini app
and have it built into Gmail so
that they can access your app
without having to leave Gmail.
It's kind of like breaking
the cycle of, oh, I'm
working in Gmail.
Oh, I've get a pop
out, go to another app.
And then, oh, I've got
to get back into Gmail.
DREA ALPHONSO: Too many clicks!
WES CHUN: Exactly.
And your context
is kind of crazy.
So if you can actually build
in a little bit of your app
within Gmail, that gives
for a better, seamless user
experience.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
DREA ALPHONSO:
Lots of cool stuff.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
So last question,
if people want to get
started on any of this,
where should they go?
WES CHUN: Sure.
Best place to go is
developers.google.com.
And you can find
App Script there.
You can find App Maker their,
Gmail add-ons, Google Drive,
and Team Drives.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank
you so much, Wes.
WES CHUN: All right, take care.
See you guys.
Have fun.
DREA ALPHONSO: Hey,
everyone, we're
here at the Cloud Spanner
booth with Selena.
So before we talk about
what we're doing here,
Selena, tell us more about
what you do at Google.
SELENA SALAZAR: I do product
marketing for GCP databases.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, we're
at the Spanner booth.
And Spanner is something that
I'm particularly excited about.
DREA ALPHONSO: Yes, you are.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I certainly am.
I've talked a lot about it.
But I've always been
frustrated by having
to choose between
horizontal scaling
and strong transactional
consistency.
But with Spanner I
don't have to choose.
SELENA SALAZAR: Yeah,
and you really hit
the nail on the head there.
You don't have to
choose, and that
having a relational
database that
also scales
horizontally and keeps
a strong transactional
scale is huge.
And that's what we're
really excited about.
Not to mention, it's also in the
cloud, so it's fully managed.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, that
makes it a lot more easy
to implement.
SELENA SALAZAR: Right.
DREA ALPHONSO: And where can
we go to learn more about it?
SELENA SALAZAR:
cloud.google.com/spanner.
DREA ALPHONSO: That was easy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you so much.
DREA ALPHONSO: Thanks, Selena,
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
Drea, it's almost time
for the end of our pre-show.
DREA ALPHONSO:
Oh, is it already?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
Of course, that means
it's almost time
for the final keynote.
DREA ALPHONSO: That's true.
And today's keynote
has an awesome lineup
dedicated to open source and
cloud-native architectures.
We'll do deep ties into
Kubernetes and TensorFlow.
And then we'll hear from Vint
Cerf, Vice President and Chief
internet Evangelist at Google
on the history and value
of free open-source
software for infrastructure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Next, Google
senior fellow Jeff Dean
will do a deep dive
into TensorFlow.
DREA ALPHONSO: And
then Sam Ramji,
VP of Product Management for
Compute and Developer Services
at Google Cloud, will talk
about building an open cloud.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We'll hear
from startups and the venture
capital community on how
they're leveraging the cloud
to build the next wave
of innovative products
and services.
DREA ALPHONSO: And
finally, Alison Wagonfeld,
VP of Marketing at Google Cloud,
will close out the keynote.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
let's get to it.
DREA ALPHONSO: I think
we should do that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's it for us.
But don't forget to
connect with us online.
Our Twitter handles
are on your screen.
DREA ALPHONSO: Enjoy the show.
And we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]